we are really now for the first time
seeing the rapid decline of coronavirus
cases in some states it's down to almost
a statistical zero
it's not literally zero cases but it's
statistically low enough
where there's really no spread most
people who are getting sick are not
passing it to anyone
and that's how you reduce the number of
cases this is just a good
thing let's look at the latest numbers
starting with u.s
cases nationally which have declined now
more than 93 from their peak
the peak was 255 000 cases per day in
late january
now down or early january now down below
18
000 cases per day we are really getting
there
the deaths are fortunately starting to
come down with them
deaths are now down about 87
from their peak below 500 a day from the
for
for the first time since march of 2020
deaths are at their lowest in about 15
months now is there anywhere in the u.s
where cases are going up
not really there are places where they
sort of aren't going down anymore and
they
tend to be places with low rates of
vaccination so mississippi is an example
where cases have been level for about 10
weeks they're not growing
but they're not really shrinking anymore
that's not great
they need to vaccinate but lots of
people there don't want the vaccine
it's likely that eventually the places
with lower vaccination rates are going
to just see continued clusters
while the highly vaccinated states are
going to go down to again statistically
zero not
literally zero but almost in terms of
globally
in south america things are not good and
i was just looking at what's going on in
my
birth country of argentina and it's a
disaster
but overall it's not just american cases
and deaths that are coming down
global cases are now declining pretty
rapidly from their peak at one point
globe we had 830
000 new global cases per day that's now
down about 40 percent
to 485 000 cases per day down
almost half uh and then global deaths
are also
more slowly declining but down
about 25 from their peak at one point
thousand humans per day were dying from
covid
we still have about eleven thousand
dying per day
of this virus uh overwhelmingly it's
happening in the least
vaccinated countries re restating
underlining the importance of getting
vaccines uh to all parts of the world
this is not over but in some places it
will effectively be over
soon more mass mandates are being pulled
uh in states were pulled over memorial
day weekend
the vaccines work well against the
variants so
it's not time to go crazy and do stupid
stuff i think at this point we all know
what is what is considered stupid at
this point in time large gatherings of
unvaccinated people indoors
is basically the stupidest thing you can
do but vaccinated people can do
most things with what we would call
baseline risk
and this is a really important concept
to understand because
psychologically the pandemic has really
shaken up our concept
of the risks we accept by existing in
the world
risk wasn't zero before this pandemic
you could go out and you could get a
cold you could go out and you could get
the flu and sometimes people die of the
flu you could go out and pick up a
stomach bug through
physical contact or in a restaurant or
whatever you could get in a car accident
so the question for me is not when is
the risk of covet zero
but it's when is it low enough that we
would consider when i go out
i'm at baseline risk meaning i'm
accepting that
generally there's some risk to being in
the world but there's not this acute
thing and vaccines
are a huge part of getting back to that
baseline level of risk of just being
alive and existing in the world
even staying home you could fall down
the stairs i get it even
staying home you could poison yourself
with lead pain i don't know
but but the point here is there are lots
of people
who before this pandemic were accepting
risks by being out in the world that
maybe they didn't even
quantify and i think that now because
we're so aware of it
it's going to feel scarier and like i
get it i was
uh you know i the other day at the
grocery store
um there just before uh
more mass guidelines were pulled there
were already a bunch of people without
masks i was wearing my mask because that
was the rules at the time and i see the
people without the mask and it's like
whoa whoa
it's like you visualize a stream of
germs coming out of their mouth
we accepted that before right for my 30
whatever years that i lived until the
pandemic i accepted that and didn't
think twice about it
the question is when will we be back to
that and then
is that an acceptable level of risk for
some people going back to the old level
of risk for example a flu
won't be acceptable and people are going
to continue wearing a mask
and that's fine but it's going back to
normal but it's sort of a new normal
where i think all of us are more aware
of the risk to just being out in the
world now one last thing
vaccination keeps slowing down in the
u.s
even though there are tons more people
to vaccinate daily vaccine doses are
down to 1.5 million a day
at one point they were at more than
double that 3.3 million a day
there are tons of people still to
vaccinate
if they don't get vaccinated some are
going to get covered
and some are going to die and many
doctors believe that
because this is going to keep
circulating if you're not vaccinated
that it's almost certain at some point
you will get it
um something to think about and that
let's now talk a little more
about the psychological impact of this
pandemic